bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live pour cette
émission spéciale vacances d'été nous
sommes en direct pendant une heure
environ pour répondre à toutes vos
questions et vous livrer les conseils de
spécialistes
quelles sont les tendances de
réservations pour cet été 2010 21 dans
quelles conditions allons nous pouvoir
voyager comment fonctionne le pass
sanitaires européens par exemple peut-on
partir à l'étranger et d'ailleurs et si
oui dans quel pays et comment on vous
dit tout grâce à nos experts aujourd'hui
en direct avec nous didier arino
directeur général de protourisme cabinet
de conseil spécialisé en tourisme et
loisirs il est en direct avec nous via
skype depuis ses bureaux à bordeaux
bonjour didier arino merci d'être avec
nous ce matin en direct avec nous
également florent mallet rédacteur en
chef adjoint au figaro voyage merci
florent d'être également avec nous en
plateau pour nous faire bénéficier de
votre expertise vous le voyez nous
sommes prêts pour vous et pour vous
livrer un maximum de conseils et
d'informations pour vous aider à
finaliser vos vacances et à vous
rassurer
et à propos de vous rassurer je me
tourne vers vous florent les dernières
annonces gouvernementales qui nous
déconseille de voyager en espagne et au
portugal deux pays qui font face à une
recrudescence de l'épidémie covit 19 bat
inquiète certainement les français qui
ont prévu de partir vers ces
destinations comme gilles sur
lefigaro.fr qui nous dit que ton voyager
en espagne au portugal désormais qu'est
ce qu'on peut leur répondre florent
payet alors ce qu'on peut répondre agile
et à nos internautes en général c'est
que le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
pour un secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes clément boon a quand même
vraiment manqué diplomatie on va
reprendre ses déclarations vous allez
voir que c'est beaucoup plus simple que
ce qu'ont pensé pour illustrer vos
propos on voit cette carte officielle du
gouvernement qui indique et on ne
reviendra dessus les pays dans lesquels
le virus circule ou pas en nombre ou pas
je vous écoute leur on vous écoute voilà
ce qu'a dit clément bonne hier matin
ceux qui n'ont pas encore réservé leurs
vacances éviter l'espagne le portugal
dans vos destinations c'est un conseil
de prudence et une recommandation sur
laquelle j'insiste aller dans d'autres
pays plusieurs remarques à ce stade là
si on fait l'exégèse vraiment d'euskadi
nôtre
secrétaire d'état aujourd'hui le
gouvernement déconseille déjà de voyager
à l'étranger et en europe également
aller dans d'autres pays
oui mais lesquelles et là il répond pas
du tout à la question si demain je ne
réservent plus en espagne mais que je
vais en grèce et qu'on me déconseille à
nouveau d'y aller qu'est ce que je fais
dit et enfin ils parlent de mesures
renforcées mais il n'utilise pas le
terme d'interdiction
ce qui s'est passé en réalité c'est que
le gouvernement dès hier après-midi a
allumé un petit peu les contre-feux
trois ministres l'ont plus ou moins
tempéré ses propos et pas plus tard que
ce matin olivier ferrand est revenu là
dessus et là plus ou moins évacués ce
qui est important de dire à ce stade là
c'est pas de panique et il a évoqué
lui-même il y à un conseil de défense
sanitaire qui se tiendra lundi qui va
notamment évoqué ce point avec le
président de la république exactement
mâcon l'enjeu en terme de voyages
puisque c'est le sujet qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir quelle va
être la couleur qui va revenir à
l'espagne ou au portugal
aujourd'hui ces deux pays sont en verre
et on peut tout à fait y aller où ils
sont en vert depuis le 1er juillet date
à laquelle a été livré cette carte que
vous voyez en ce moment à l'image
effectivement sur cette carte le
portugal et l'espagne sont toujours en
vert or le fil le virus circule
probablement aujourd'hui dans une
proportion qui ferait qu elle devrait
normalement ces deux pays devraient
changer de couleur on y reviendra tout à
l'heure je salue khemissi sur le chat du
figaro via youtube qui nous demandent
voyager au portugal est ce que c'est
possible quelles sont les conditions au
retour
est-ce qu'on peut répondre à camille see
as khemissi djellabi dia qui a
probablement ce projet de partir au
portugal mais qui s'inquiètent d'un
possible retour est ce que vous pouvez
lui répond didier arino évidemment aller
au portugal
ces vacances puisque le portugal comme
l'ensemble des pays européens sont en
vert sur la carte
quand on a un schéma vaccinal complet
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on a eu les deux doses
depuis plus de quatorze jours on peut
revenir du portugal sans difficulté sans
test en revanche si non il faut un un
test pcr et
l'obligation du test pcr un grosso modo
si on doit simplifier les choses
si on est vaccinés on peut aller dans
les pays européens
si on n'est pas vacciné il faut un test
pcr à l'aller et au retour avec des
règles qui changent en revanche suivant
les pays
puisque par exemple pour l'italie si on
y va et que des enfants
il faut à faire des tests à partir de
l'âge de 6 ans pour d'autres pays
ces onze ans et il ya quelques
restrictions il ya des pays qui qui
donne des restrictions un petit peu plus
forte
y compris des restrictions de
quarantaine pour ceux qui ne seraient
pas vaccinés on a eu le cas de
l'autriche et notamment et du danemark
mais ces règles sont évolutives ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que notre
gouvernement met en place une carte et
ce sont les règles pour les départs de
nos concitoyens vers ces pays mais les
pays qui nous accueille ont leurs
propres règles et donc on doit aussi
vérifier les règles de des pays
accueillant on peut avoir des systèmes
de quarantaine dans certains dans
certains pays c'est le cas notamment en
algérie ou en tunisie lorsque l'on n'est
pas vaccinée on peut avoir des règles
qui sont des règles de tests pcr ou de
testant tigenix certains pays demandent
des tests pcr de moins de 72 heures
d'autres moins de 48 heures
donc vraiment il faut il faut vérifier
cela c'est tellement et politiques
d'ailleurs que même sur les sites de
voyages à je regardais le le site du
dieu du routard dans lesquels il ya une
erreur notamment sur le maroc parce que
le maroc il ya plus de motifs impérieux
et alors cette confusion elle existe
aussi chez les douaniers alors ça c'est
problématique
il ya des cas de personnes qui ont voulu
partir au maroc la semaine dernière qui
avaient leurs passeports sanitaire avec
et qui sont arrivés en comment passer le
moment où il en est arrivé à la poste
frontière le douanier lordinot non le
maroc c'est un motif impérieux c'est
totalement faux mais en attendant ils
n'ont pas pu prendre leur vol
non seulement ils n'ont pas pu prendre
leur vol mais comme bien évidemment le
douanier vous donne pas un papier en
disant c'est un motif impérieux vous
pouvez pas embarquer ils ne peuvent pas
se faire rembourser donc
dans des situations qui sont assez
dramatique parce que la compagnie
aérienne part du principe que le vol lui
il arrive il a eu lieu que dans pour eux
c'est ce qu'on appelle un au chaud c'est
à dire un client qui ne se présentent
pas ça ne se présente pas et donc c'est
une vraie vraie difficulté
donc on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
confusion sur tous ces sujets est
véritablement alors quand on part à
l'étranger
il est quand même préférable de passer
par une agence de voyages ça c'est
vraiment ce que je conseille et une
agence de voyages traditionnelles un pas
une agence en ligne où vous n'aurez
aucun contact si vous avez le moindre
problème et avec de grandes difficultés
pour vous faire rembourser lagence de
voyage à côté de chez vous car là vous
aurez un interlocuteur ça sera beaucoup
plus facile de vous faire rembourser et
si vous avez affaire à un douanier
récalcitrants au moins vous pourrez
avoir le document est demandé à l'
agence de voyages qui montre bien le
texte du gouvernement sur les
destinations auxquelles on a accès ou
pas didier arino juste pour répondre
très brièvement à par rapport à ce que
vous venez de dire je rebondis sur les
questions de dragon malek qui nous dit
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a toujours
besoin de se faire vacciner pour voyager
du court il faut lui il faut le lui
conseillez quoi exactement là alors est
ce qu'on a besoin de se faire vacciner
si on regarde besoin de se faire
vacciner ce qu'est des pays qui accepte
des gens ne soient pas vaccinés par
exemple oui bien sûr il ya des pays qui
accepte que les gens ne soient pas
vacciner c'est le cas notamment et c'est
ce qu'a ce qui a généré 2 de la
confusion aujourd'hui on peut arriver on
peut aller en espagne sans être vaccinés
ces il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
règle aujourd'hui de nécessité de
vaccination il ya d'autres pays qui vous
accepte sans restriction c'est le cas
notamment de la république dominicaine
du costa rica du mexique mais dans la
plupart des pays pour la plupart des
pays il faut une vaccination pour ceux
qui sont ouverts
car rappelons que quand on regarde la
situation du monde
on ne peut pas aller aux états unis dans
les grands pays touristique on ne peut
pas leur en australie on ne peut pas
aller en asie ou alors avec des
contraintes énormes si vous voulez le
cambodge
vous avez une période de quarantaine
faut donner une caution de 2000 $
on est vraiment dans des situations
extrêmement extrêmement compliqué donc
dans la plupart des pays il ya des pays
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de vols on
peut pas y accéder c'est le cas c'est le
cas du brésil donc on voit bien que dans
la plupart des régions du monde il ya
des contraintes soient elles sont
fermées soit les contraintes sont des
contraintes très fortes
il ya que ce qui compte vraiment qu'ils
ont vraiment véritablement besoin du
tourisme c'est le cas notamment de la
république dominicaine qui ne donne
aucune contrainte
didier arino merci pour votre expertise
on va continuer évidemment à vous poser
des questions et vous allez continuer à
informer les internautes
si vous venez nous rejoindre nous sommes
là pour vous et pour répondre à vos
questions en rapport avec vos vacances
d'été si vous les avez déjà calé réservé
où vous êtes sur le point de les
réserver en particulier sur des
destinations qui pose aujourd'hui un
problème puisqu'il il ya certains pays
qui connaissent une recrudescence de
l'épidémie de kobe 19 on parlait à
l'instant du portugal et de l'espagne
je salue adrien léger lucie valais sur
le chat du figaro.fr
je salue également sofia du portique sur
le chat du figaro live sur youtube vous
avez de nombreuses questions en rapport
avec vos vacances et la question
principale que vous posez c'est est-ce
que vous devez annuler je vois adrien
léger qui nous dit bonjour à tous
est-ce que je dois annuler mes vacances
en espagne et si oui est ce que je serai
remboursé
lucie valley qui nous dit bonjour est ce
que toutes les compagnies prévoient un
remboursement ou un échange en cash
d'annulation pour des raisons sanitaires
de la même façon que sofia du portique
s'interroge sur dans l'hypothèse d'un
durcissement des mesures sanitaires ou
bien d'un test kobe de positif
quid du remboursement des réservations
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur répond didier
arino sur cette éventualité de devoir
annuler ses congés et ses billets
d'avion que vont faire les compagnies
aériennes alors à partir du moment où la
destination est ouverte ce qui est le
cas des destinations européennes
si vous prenez l'initiative d'annuler
votre séjour par exemple en espagne ou
au portugal
vous ne serez pas remboursés ça c'est
clair y'a pas le remboursement s'impose
à partir du moment où les frontières
sont fermées ce terrier une interdiction
de voyager ce qui n'est pas le cas et
c'est là que la déclaration du ce
les terres de l'état est ambiguë on peut
pour résumer partir en sécurité dans la
plupart des pays européens
ça suppose d'être vigilants sur les
gestes barrières mais un petit peu comme
chez nous sur les protocoles sanitaires
sont respectées il ya quelques
contraintes par exemple à lisbonne il ya
un couvre-feu
donc faut accepter ses contraintes après
on peut se poser la question pour un
confort personnel si on décide en en se
disant bon ça serait on aura moins de
liberté en partant à l'étranger dans
telle ou telle province espagnole
notamment en catalogne ou à lisbonne et
qu'on décide de renoncer à ses vacances
on ne sera pas remboursé donc c'est très
important et le risque il est
extrêmement limitée
le la meilleure façon de se prémunir et
c'est d'être vaccinés c'est la meilleure
des façons de se prémunir
car on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui à
partir du moment où on est vacciné et
qu'on fait un minimum attention on a un
risque est extrêmement limité de
contracter le virus en tout cas d'en
faire des formes graves
après si on veut partir en vacances on
fait faire un test pcr pour les pays qui
le kill qui le demandent mais souvent il
ya aussi un test pcr
retour donc ça une contrainte chez nous
en france les tests sont gratuits et
d'ailleurs ce qui peut poser quand même
quelques questions
il ya ceux qui font un test pcr pour
aller acheter des cigarettes ou de
l'alcool en andorre à la charge du
contribuable on peut se demander si ça
une vraie utilité si ça a du sens en
revanche si on veut partir à l'étranger
ont fait un test pcr
à l'aller on fait un test pcr au retour
sachant qu'en espagne le coût du test
pcr est entre 75 et 150 euros
et ça il faut le savoir c'est un coup il
n'y a que chez nous pour les français
que le test pcr et gratuit didier didier
à un pardon fleurs envoyées c'est un
poids
très important ces conditions
d'annulation et de remboursement à ce
jour on l'a donc dit en espagne on a
tout à fait le droit d'y aller au
portugal on a tout à fait le droit d'y
aller il faut surtout pas annuler
pourquoi les avions sont maintenus comme
le souligne didier arino il n'y a pas de
changement fondamental qui justifierait
un remboursement un cas de force majeure
on considère pas ça fait maintenant 18
mois qu'on a à peu près le recul que les
pays faire rouvre stores des couvre feux
etc
on ne considère pas a priori qu'un
couvre-feu va changer l'économie de
votre voyage que ça va bouleverser votre
vie sur place etc
et quand bien même on passerait
l'espagne en changera de couleur
l'espagne il faudrait être vaccinés pour
y aller les non vaccinés ont accès aux
vaccins en france
on peut donc penser que ce ne sera pas
un cas de force majeure donc adapter
réadapter ses vacances à l'heure où on
se parle c'est pas une nécessité absolue
par rapport à ce que vous êtes en train
de nous dire exactement ce que nos
intérieurs didier arino les vols sont
maintenus on est les compagnies ariennes
encore ce matin qui pour l'instant
maintienne en l'état les vols les vols
ne sont donc pas annuler les
hébergements que vous aurez réserver sur
place ils n'ont pas de raison d'annuler
puisque les français peuvent venir
si jamais seul les français vaccinés
peuvent y aller ils peuvent également
tout à fait vous répondre vous êtes
libre de vous vacciner en france vous ne
le faites pas ça ne regarde pas qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire en revanche à hasnon
de six diables kylie qui nous dit mon
conjoint n'est pas vacciné mais moi je
le suis est ce un problème
c'est un problème si vous voyagez en
couple et que la destination que vous
visez
par exemple passe en orange si on est un
orange qui est une des hypothèses
qui devrait être peut-être annoncé lundi
pour l'espagne ou le portugal et bien
seules les personnes vaccinées pourront
y aller
le touriste n'est pas un motif impérieux
pour les personnes non vaccinées
je salue mandelson un qui vient de nous
rejoindre sur le chat du figaro.fr
figaro live et qui nous demande le
passeport vaccinale est il remplacé par
le certificat qu'ovide européen qu'est
ce qu'on peut lui répondre
ben c'est le nom technique en fait qu'il
a utilisée c'est exactement la même
chose
et là encore il ya beaucoup de confusion
c'est un peu ce que disait didier arino
avant les déclarations du ministre où
ces changements un peu sémantique
introduisent beaucoup de confusion pour
faire très simple si vous êtes vacciné
en france si vous faites un test pcr si
vous faites un test antigénique il
suffit de scanner le qr code et de le
transposer dans votre application to
syndicaux vide ou autre solution vous
présenter tout simplement avec la
version papier c'est autorisé mandelson
un toujours merci à lui d'avoir posé ces
questions ce matin
faut-il s'inquiéter d'un éventuel
reconfirme ans pendant les vacances
d'été
effectivement on s'inquiète ce qu'ils
ont prévu leurs vacances d'été en
particulier sur le mois d'août après la
après la mi août par exemple si un
confinement envisagée est ce que c'est
le cas est-ce que c'est dans les tuyaux
est-ce que vous avez des infos par
rapport à ça florent payet le seul
problème qu'on voit venir alors en
l'état une seule certitude il va falloir
attendre lundi et voir ce que décide le
gouvernement pour préjuger de ce qui
pourrait se passer plus tard ce qu'ont
ceux dont on est à peu près sûr
aujourd'hui c'est que la fameuse
quatrième vague
elle devrait arriver en août elle
devrait arriver en france elle le sera
peut-être déjà arrivés dans ces autres
pays
si déconfinement sont décrétés ça change
effectivement la perspective de voyage
c'est à dire que si vous allez sur place
et qu'on vous dit ben non vous ne pouvez
plus sortir à partir de 15h et c est là
on aura un vrai risque est un vrai
danger sur le voyage mais par définition
ce sont des choses qui sont prises avec
un effet de décalage dans le temps en
général entre le début d'une
de tests positifs et le passage d'un
pays où le changement de couleurs d'un
pays c'est cool 14 à 15 jours donc c'est
très difficile de le prévoir à ce stade
là ce qui est sûr c'est que si le
gouvernement ne rassure pas lundi les
français pour les réservations de
voyages ça posera un gros problème ça
posera un problème d'autant plus
important que les étrangers aussi
peuvent venir en france et que le
secrétaire d'état au tourisme a même
fait un road trip pour dire aux
étrangers venaient en france tout sera
bien etc
on imagine les mesures de réciprocité si
les belges ou les néerlandais
il ya en ce moment également des cas
importants qui sont déclarés aux
pays-bas et bien disent à leurs
ressortissants n'allait pas en france
vous êtes en direct avec nous sur figaro
l'arrivée sur la chaîne figaro live sur
youtube vous pouvez nous poser vos
questions en direct vos commentaires
également rapports avec vos vacances
d'été vos inquiétudes ou tout simplement
votre enthousiasme pour pas de partir en
vacances prochainement malgré voilà ce
qu'on nous annonce sur de possibles
restrictions éventuellement en tout cas
cette augmentation du nombre de cas qu
vite dans certains pays européens et
quelques cluster en france on a parlé de
l'espagne on a parlé du portugal et de
certains pays européens mais didier
arino ils partent ou les vacances les
français cet été qu'elle est
quelles sont les destinations choisies
par paradou ressortissants pour ses
sautes mar 21 parcs les français ils
partent massivement si on a des chiffres
record de départs en vacances pour cet
été avec 4 millions de plus qu une année
classique et 2 millions de plus que l'an
passé
ils partent à la mer c'est la tendance
de l'année mais c'est une tendance assez
classique plus que l'an passé où l'an
passé les réservations dans le littoral
se sont fait un peu plus tardivement
mais ils partent aussi massivement à la
campagne et à la montagne
on voit que cette année les français
comme l'an passé d'ailleurs recherche
les grands espaces que ce soit les
grandes plages de l'atlantique ou de la
méditerranée mais aussi des destinations
plus rurales des destinations de
moyennes montagnes de piémont et ça
c'est un peu la nouveauté
je pense à une destination comme le
béarn cette année qui est très très bien
réserver dans les différentes vallées
que ce soit la validation la vallée
so la vallée de barétous ce et on voit
des comportements qui évolue vers un
tourisme beaucoup plus doux d'ailleurs
il ya un allongement de la durée moyenne
de séjour puisque nous sommes passés de
10 jours en moyenne l'an passé à douze
jours cette année 7 des français qui
sont plus nombreux à partir ils sont
aussi frustré de 9 de ne pas avoir pu
partir cet hiver et ce printemps et donc
il regroupe l'essentiel de leurs
vacances sur cette saison estivale en
choisissant d'ailleurs plutôt de la
qualité vers les hébergements qui ont
été réservés en priorité sont les
hébergements les plus qualitatifs que ce
soit dans les meubles et les maisons
avec piscine par exemple que ce soit
dans les campings plutôt les campings
haut de gamme avec des jolies mobile
home avec des chalets bois un des
chaînes comme comme sunêlia sont très
très bien réserver ou ou yelloh village
ou sans d'ailleurs mais on a aussi une
recherche de camping plus en phase avec
les espaces naturels et là par exemple
un opérateur comme comme flower campings
qui répartis sur le territoire national
et fonctionnent très bien d'ailleurs il
ya encore des disponibilités
dansez dansez campi et puis il ya aussi
un engouement pour des résidences de
tourisme nouvelle génération et à la
montagne et à la campagne on voit un
opérateur d'ailleurs en ce moment il ya
une promotion chez vacances et où l'on
peut sans euros de réduction j'en parle
parce qu'elles sont assez rares les
promotions en ce moment les bons plans
de didier arino voilà elles sont elles
sont assez rares les promotions là cette
année dont classés c'est un bon plan
vous allez sur les résidences de
tourisme la console vous avez des des
tarifs qui sont tout à fait attractifs
pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore réservé
ou lorsqu'on veut aller dans un dans un
camping très haut de gamme y en a
quelques-uns avec la disponibilité il y
en a y'en a un qui s'appelle le fief
c'est un camping sunêlia père l'a dit
marc et encore c'est parce que la corse
a aussi c'est une destination qui a
repris des couleurs cette année avec
beaucoup plus de nos concitoyens qui
partent en corse
encore faut-il trouver des billets
d'avion et des locations de voiture mais
on voit bien qu'il ya une belle
répartition de la fréquentation dans
l'est dans les espaces naturels
cette envie de nature aussi de rétro
littoral la bretagne est très bien
réserver que ce soit la côte de granit
rose ou le golfe du morbihan mais envoie
une destination de l'intérieur coeur de
bretagne qui a qui génère un certain
nombre ou man 1 c'est à la fois les
monts d'arrée c'est le canal de nantes à
brest c'est des châteaux c'est la
famille des rohan c'est donc on voit
bien qu'il ya sept
il ya cette tendance vers vers de la
pleine nature etc
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour les
destinations où la provence occitane
kevin destination extrêmement bien
réserver cette année donc on voit que
les français se répartissent sur le
territoire national ou la drôme l'ain la
drôme à à de très belles réservation
aussi d'ailleurs ça peut être assez
amusant parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit que
les gens recherchent rejette plutôt les
grandes métropoles et les villes mais on
peut être dans une petite ville à partir
de laquelle on peut rayonner embargo
rites et découvrir les destinations je
prends deux villes où il ya une ville où
il ya un parc hôtelier une ville comme
valence à partir de laquelle on peut
rayonner vers l'ardèche vers la drôme
intérieur et ça c'est tout à fait
intéressant on a aussi ce même phénomène
à partir d'une ville comme pau il ya un
gros parc hôtelier où les tarifs sont
adressés attractif en été et à partir
d'une ville comme pau on peut rayonner
vers les vallées 1 laval et das la
vallée d'ossau
mais on peut aussi aller visiter les
caves du jurançon de madiran l'irouléguy
on peut aller découvrir les producteurs
de soya ratti à l'est aussi dans le pays
basque intérieur
aller vers les grands cols des pyrénées
donc on voit bien qu'il ya aussi cette
tendance vers l'itinérance et tous ceux
qui propose d'ailleurs de l'itinérance
de qualité avec une expérience client
forte cela fonctionne très bien et puis
il ya l'autre aspect qui est un aspect
très important bien évidemment les
familles se pose la question lorsqu'ils
partent en vacances que puis-je faire
avec des enfants et là aussi on a dans
toutes les filières
un travail tout à fait considérable pour
aussi séduire les enfants je pense à
allonnes au tourisme un château comme
marquis terme à les déguster du vin bien
évidemment pour les enfants ça paraît
c'est pas le but
donc là on apprend à déguster à
découvrir à partager il ya des gars des
jeux ya de plus en plus des parcs qui
sont aménagés
donc on voit que tout ce travail qui est
fait par les par les acteurs est
extrêmement important avec un
développement et des choses qui marchent
très bien autour des activités de pleine
nature
la tyrolienne notamment les descentes en
canoë toutes les activités qu'on peut
partager en famille où il ya un petit
peu de sensation un petit peu de
d'expérience forte et puis bien
évidemment on a un retour vers les les
parcs à thème qui ont été fermés pendant
de longs mois
le puy du fou le futuroscope je pense à
un château qui est vraiment très
intéressant aussi en berne qui s'appelle
le château de laas et qui permet d'avoir
des énigmes c'est vraiment le type de
destination qu'on peut faire en famille
et à des prix de d'ailleurs tout à fait
raisonnable avec de très bons rapports
qualité prix
et puis ensuite il ya les destinations
les grandes destinations emblématiques
du tourisme français cette année par
exemple le pays basque est très bien
réserver on peut faire un pas de côté
aller vers le pays basque intérieur
on en allant découvrir la vallée des
aldudes qui est absolument sublime ou
dans les destinations emblématiques y
ait encore quelques disponibilités
intéressante que ce soit sur le bassin
d'arcachon ou sur la côte landaise
tout ce que vous nous dites et
passionnant on a envie de tout faire
bien entendu et et on s'imagine déjà
plongée et faire de la tyrolienne pour
certains florent payet par rapport à ce
que vient de nous dire didier arino vous
souhaitiez peut-être apporter un
complément d'information plusieurs
remarques et notamment vous avez abordé
la question didier des bons plans on est
quand même sur un été une configuration
où globalement les prix sont en hausse
on a parlé des locations de maisons il
ya des moyennes qui oscille entre +10 et
+ 15 % du prix de location des maisons à
la semaine puisque c'est évidemment un
produit très recherché est pas parce qu
il ya ya ya ya peu d'offres par rapport
à la demande
il ya trop de demande par rapport à
l'offre alors il ya la même offre avec
un phénomène aussi où les gens peuvent
garder les maisons qui louait auparavant
pour eux pour leurs proches et c'est
donc c'est aussi des maisons qui sont
sortis du marché et il ya un autre
phénomène aussi didier en a parlé sur la
corse mais n'y a pas qu'en corse c'est
il ya une pénurie de location de
voitures voilà
et on sait d'ores et déjà que sur
certaines destinations on a cité la
corse il ya d'autres destinations
notamment dans le sud-est qui sont très
prisés et on va avoir du mal à réserver
la voiture si on n'a pas déjà fait c'est
oui peut-être aussi les camping cars qui
connaissent un succès assez conséquent
cette année flamands y est tout à fait
ça revient au la notion d'itinérance
qu'on abordait qu'on abordait juste
avant camping-car vanille effectivement
une très grosse demande et beaucoup de
curiosité des français pour le faire et
pour redécouvrir son pays
didier arino ont parlé de l'explosion
des réservations dans le sud est de la
france en particulier dans le var en
préparant cette émission j'ai vu que par
exemple aux issambres
il y avait une augmentation considérable
du nombre de locations
pourquoi cette affluence massive sur
cette région particulière en france
et bien parce que c'est la destination
soleil plage mer par excellence et tous
ceux qui envisageaient de partir vers
des destinations plus lointaines et qui
se sont rabattus sur la france
il recherche des destinations avec une
garantie de soleil et donc il ya un
regain cette année de la côte d'azur
mais là aussi il peut y avoir des bons
plans c'est que il ya une partie de la
côte d'azur je pense à une ville comme
nice qui dépend habituellement très
fortement des clientèles lointaines des
clientèles étrangères que ce soit
asiatiques ou américaines
et aujourd'hui il ya un gros parc
hôtelier à nice et on peut faire un
séjour à nice dans une très belle
hôtellerie à des prix extrêmement
raisonnable
c'est peut-être cette année qu'il faut
retourner à l'hôtel qu'il faut aller
dans les hôtels parce que il ya des prix
attractifs dans des destinations où
justement il manque les clientèles
étrangères alors que ce soit nice et on
peut passer un séjour à des prix très
raisonnables un pas vraiment pas plus
cher voire moins cher que certains que
certains meublé avec du service quand
même et avec un respect d'un protocole
sanitaire dans l'hôtellerie
il ya un opérateur qui est un opérateur
qui s'appelle vacances bleues
là aussi avec des prix raisonnables on
n'est pas dans du haut de gamme landais
dans une dans une offre avec un très bon
rapport qualité prix mais avec des
emplacements de très grande qualité et
donc on peut passer un séjour chez
vacances bleues à des prix tout à fait
raisonnable et puis on peut aller aussi
dans des villes où il ya de l'eau qu'ils
font qui fait du bien
ou on peut dans le raid dans une
démultiplication des activités de pleine
nature en normandie pas très loin de
paris je pense est une ville comme
bagnoles de l'orne dans laquelle on peut
vraiment pratiquer des activités là
aussi il ya un pôle hôtelier qui est un
pôle important
donc c'est cette année qu'il faut
regarder parce qu'on peut véritablement
aller à l'hôtel est souvent les familles
n'ont pas ce réflexe parce qu'ils se
disent l'hôtel c'est pas c'est pas pour
nous ou même les coupes et s'il ya ce et
notamment les plus jeunes qui ont été
habitués qui se sont habitués à utiliser
les plateformes de location en ligne et
qui ne vont plus à l'hôtel alors que
vivre une expérience avec un vrai
service dans une baie l'hôtellerie
française c'est quand même quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et cette année c'est le
moment c'est le moment d'aller aussi
dans des villes comme bordeaux de
redécouvrir paris pour les provinciaux
parce que forcément y'a pas les
étrangers
didier arino vous nous faites la
promotion cette année de l'idée qu'il
faut réserver à l'hôtel pour ceux qui
n'ont pas encore réservé leurs vacances
et non pas prendre une location en tout
cas a priori les tarifs sont plus
intéressants à l'hôtel il ya des il ya
des tarifs et des promotions
intéressantes en ce moment et c'est
peut-être l'hôtel sur lequel il faut se
rabattre en préparant cette émission
florent manniez j'ai vu qu effectivement
cette année c'est l'explosion des
réservations de maison les gens les gens
et les vacanciers ont envie de se
retrouver en famille ils ont loué des
maisons plus grande pour accueillir un
peu plus de monde c'est ça en fait les
vacances 2021 pour l'été des tendances
et puisque vous parliez notamment delà
de la côte d'azur il ya quand même un
problème qui va falloir aborder et puis
certains internautes ont d'ailleurs
n'ont pas manqué de le souligner c'est
la concentration quand même deux
personnes en plusieurs endroits qui sont
déjà réputé et malheureusement c'est
maintenant avéré qu'ils sont en
situation de sur fréquentation
touristique
on a beaucoup parlé des calanques de
marseille a pas que les calanques de
marseille si on reste dans cette zone du
sud est il ya quand même une décision
qui est pas loin peut-être d'être une
première en france c'est la presqu'île
c'est le lille pardon de porquerolles
dans le var dont pas très loin d'y et a
pas très loin des résistants consitait
consisté à vent qui pour la première
fois cet été a décidé de limiter les
touristes quotidien on parle d'une jauge
fixé à
mille personnes ce sera pas sur tout
l'été mais on part d'une situation où
lors des pics doute on avait quand même
douze mille visiteurs quotidiens on
passerait 2000 à 6000 on a une jauge et
on a très clairement un mouvement qui
fait dire voilà il ya trop de monde
il ya des problèmes historiques de
préservation de la nature de
sur-fréquentation etc qui se télescope
avec cette actualité du coc vie dont
vous dis attention gardez vos distances
etc
et ça risque quand même de poser
problème dans ces zones et notamment le
sud est et si on décourage pas les gens
d'y aller un pas du tout et c'est ce qui
fait dire d'ailleurs on interrogé hier
le responsable de l'office de tourisme
du portugal qui me disaient mais quels
risques que vous prenez en venant au
portugal en étant sur nos plages de
l'atlantique ou en restant en france
et finalement on peut vraiment se poser
la question est ce qu'il ya une
différence et bien justement on va
reparler des questions sanitaires qui
vous posent beaucoup d'interrogations et
vous êtes nombreux à vous interroger un
toujours sur la façon dont vont se
dérouler vos vacances d'un point de vue
sanitaire si des restrictions vont
s'imposer
mandelson un que je re ça lui qui nous a
déjà posé un certain nombre de questions
nous demande faudra-t-il porter son mas
à la plage
or mandelson 1 il a vraiment envie de
partir elle a besoin de vacances
vraiment que ça tombe bien
mandelson un a priori ce sera pas le cas
en france et même pas à l'étranger
d'ailleurs là l'espagne a commencé par
tomber le masque sur la plage avant de
tomber dans la rue pour le moment en pré
rien ne nous garantit qu au fil de l'été
des mesures ne seront pas prises une des
mesures considérées comme les plus light
entre guillemets c'est effectivement le
port du masque sofia du portique merci à
elle elle est sur le chat du figaro via
la chaîne youtube figaro live le fait
d'être positif au qu'ovide
constitue-t-il un cas de force majeur de
nature à permettre un remboursement de
ses réservations pour l'été
c'est une question intéressante qu'on a
posé aux assurés en essayant d'avoir une
réponse précise vous cache pas que c'est
pas clair néanmoins ce qu'il apparaisse
et que l'on modifie
la perspective de son voyage quand on
est déclaré positif au cowitz qu'on peut
recommander puisque c'est effectivement
même si vous êtes vacciné
une éventualité c'est de souscrire une
assurance vous pouvez souscrire une
assurance voyage vous avez 14 jours pour
vous rétracter
si jamais vous êtes déclaré positif
avant de partir vous passez par votre
assurance est a priori vous avez des
chances relativement sérieuse vous faire
rembourser prendre une assurance voyage
c'est toujours une question qu'on se
pose effectivement avant de partir parce
que on redoute le coût de l'assurance
voyage
certains estiment qu'ils sont de fait
protégés par leur assurance personnelle
par la carte visa premier en particulier
et qui n'ont pas besoin de prendre une
assurance supplémentaire est ce qu'on
peut répondre par rapport à ça et au
coût que représente une assurance voyage
en cas d'annulation alors sur
l'assurance il ya toujours une
couverture à vos besoins vous avez cité
une célèbre carte bancaire et de fait le
fait de payer votre voyage aux
prestations que soit votre billet
d'avion votre hébergement etc peut vous
protéger dans certains cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que la carte bancaire va
couvrir certains frais mais pas tous
quels sont les risques
concrètement que vous prenez en france
pas grand chose en revanche si vous
allez à l'étranger que vous êtes déclaré
positif le principe du coc vite c'est
que tant que vous êtes positif on va pas
vous rapatriez donc vous restez sur
place qu'est ce qui peut se passer sur
place vous pouvez avoir des frais
d'hébergement vous pouvez avoir des
frais d'hospitalisation et dans ce cas
là je pense qu'il est pertinent
effectivement de souscrire une assurance
voyage
la question c'est combien alors on a
fait une étude assez complète on a
comparé une dizaine d'assurance on est
sur des prix qui vont de 30 euros à 150
euros on parle par personne n'y a
évidemment pas les mêmes prestations
l'intérieur ce qu'on peut conseiller de
regarder c'est la prise en charge de
cette fameuse quarantaine didier arino
je me tourne vers vous de nouveau on a
parlé des littoraux très évidemment
fréquenter cet été en particulier le sud
est mais pas que et puis certaines
parties à la campagne certaines régions
la drôme en particulier si on veut
vraiment se tenir totalement éloignée de
tout le monde
est ce qu'il ya des zones dans
lesquelles on peut trouver encore des
locations de maisons
d autres tels sympathique où on ne
serait pas submergés par la foule
ah oui il ya des endroits où on n'est
pas submergés par la foule et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut choisir des destinations
qui sont peut-être moins réputés je
pense notamment dans le centre de la
france il ya le massif du sancy qui
fonctionne très bien mais dans lesquels
il ya encore des disponibilités je pense
aux jauges haut jura je pense à l'alsace
qui est une destination absolument
sublime et dans lesquels il ya des
disponibilités dans lesquels on peut
avoir à la fois du patrimoine des
activités de pleine nature découvrir une
culture des savoir faire
ça fait partie des belles destinations
j'évoquais le béarn tout à l'heure qui
est une formidable destinations à
découvrir l'intérieur des terres et
chaque fois qu'on sort des sentiers
battus je pense notamment en vendée en
allant plutôt dans le bocage vendéen
quand on est en bretagne en allant à
l'intérieur des terres sur le coeur de
bretagne
quand on prend aussi une destination qui
est une puis une destination l'ariège
qui est une superbe destination je pense
aussi à loudenvielle toute cette toute
cette vallée dans le dans les hautes
pyrénées où à partir de bagnères de
bigorre aussi où il ya on peut faire les
cols du tourmalet on peut aller visiter
voir les grands lacs
donc la quantité de destinations comme
ça où il faut sortir des sentiers battus
je pense qu'il ya un établissement une
commune s'appelle hagetmau dans les
landes qu'à l'intérieur des landes dans
la chalosse et là il ya un petit hôtel
qui est vraiment est très très sympa qui
s'appelle les l'agdal qu on al
impression que s'est posée comme ça un
nénuphar qui est posé sur l'eau qui est
un endroit très agréable on a perdu
didier arino absolument des vacances on
a quand même d'accord la retrouver
didier qu'il faut s'attendre dans leur
pays il faut quand même s'attendre pour
les gens qui restent en france a donc
des littoraux plutôt très fréquenté je
lis la réaction est le commentaire de
leurs ou tuer ou qui est le pseudonyme
d'un internaute qui nous suit en ce
moment sur lefigaro.fr figaro live qui
nous dit le mieux est de surtout ne pas
voyager même en france c'est son avis je
ne suis pas certaine que ce soit suivi
par beaucoup
leroux tuer ou qui nous dit également
une assurance à propos du la thématique
des assurances convient d'aborder une
assurance qui ne va pas fonctionner de
toute façon effectivement il ya
certaines certains touristes certains
voyageurs qui considère que quand un
casse présentes qui les concerne de
prise en charge par l'assurance et bien
on tombe forcément sur le moment où
l'assurance vous dis non votre cas ne
rentre pas dans les clous de ce que vous
avez soit quoi vous avez souscrit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre alors on
peut lui répondre à leurs outils ou
d'abord qu'il est assez pessimiste et
que ça ne rempilera l'état d'esprit
général
l'état d'esprit général c'est que les
gens sortent quand même d'une séquence
de 18 mois relativement pénible avec des
allers-retours déconfinement des couvre
feux etc
voilà les gens ont besoin de vacances il
ya sa porte même un nom ce phénomène on
parle de revenge travel la revanche des
voyages donc les gens ont envie de
partir cet été
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont d'autant moins
bien pris cette déclaration du
secrétaire d'état
on va pas revenir là dessus du coup les
gens de toute façon vont partir et quant
aux assurances
écoutez encore une fois libre à chacun
de décider ce qui fait on l'a dit c'est
pas forcément pertinent en restant en
france
néanmoins beaucoup de monde a quand même
vécu une situation l'an dernier ou en
échange on s'est fait remettre des
avoirs voilà c'est une question qui est
toujours pendante et dont on attend le
remboursement au bout de 18 mois en
théorie donc c'est une situation que les
gens n'ont pas forcément envie de
revivre
partant de là les gens étant plus
avertis on a quand même peut-être plus
de chance de s'éviter ces mésaventures
un autre internaute nous demande sur
lefigaro.fr
est-ce que l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu est un motif d'annulation
sous-entendu dans la région dans
laquelle ils souhaitent aller
en prévision de cet été a priori non
parce que ça va pas forcément modifier
le déroulé général de votre votre
journée de vacances on parle de
couvre-feu actuellement qu'il démarre à
23 heures est ce qu'un couvre-feu qui
démarre à 23h va vraiment gâcher vos
vacances je n'en suis pas sûr est ce
qu'un couvre-feu qui démarre à 18h va
gâcher vos vacances il ya déjà un peu
plus de chance
de fait ce n'est pas les horaires retenu
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur des
horaires tardifs
23h05 heures 22 heures 6 heures plus tôt
des choses comme ça mandelson 1 toujours
présent merci à lui qui nous demande
pour des voyages vers l'europe
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux voyager en train
en voiture ou en avion d'un point de vue
sanitaire estime-t-il alors c'est la
réponse est à tiroirs
aujourd'hui il est plus ou moins
démontré qu'en avion ou en train vous
prenez assez peu de risques même si
c'est des sujets qui font toujours
polémiquer que des études peuvent
parfois se nuancer entre elles ça semble
quand même établi évidemment vous prenez
aucun risque a priori si vous voyagez en
voiture avec vos proches
didier arino je crois que la connexion a
été rétabli entre vous et nous vous
parliez des vacances intra française on
va dire mais qu'en est il des français
qui souhaitent aller visiter du pays et
en dehors de l'espagne et du portugal
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure est-ce que
vous avez connaissance voilà deux de ces
français qui partent à l'étranger quelle
destination les a séduits pour pour cet
été et en quel pourcentage de français
partent à l'étranger cette année
alors cette année 85 % des vacanciers
restent dans l'hexagone et 15 %
envisagent de partir à l'étranger
il faut savoir qu habituellement c'est
plutôt 25 ou 30 % donc beaucoup moins de
français partent à l'étranger
mais plus que l'an passé puisque l'an
passé 94 % des vacanciers étaient restés
en france donc il ya une envie de
découvrir l'étranger de re découvrir
l'étranger mais on voit bien qu'il ya un
frein et le frein c'est la situation
sanitaire c'est la complexité de la
situation est donc de ce fait les
français restent dans l'hexagone
d'ailleurs certains vraiment apprécié de
redécouvrir la prendre on a toujours
cette tendance mais on voit bien que
dans les années qui viennent
à partir du moment où les gens pourront
voyager de façon fluide il repartir
reprendront le chemin des de l'étranger
comme les étrangers reprendront le
chemin de la france
mais didier arino justement les
étrangers est ce qu'ils vont venir cet
été en france
qui sont-ils d'où vient-il alors les
étrangers des destinations lointaines ne
viendront pas en france c'est le cas des
asiatiques très peu les américains pas
les australiens enfin la plupart des
pays lointains
en revanche la clientèle européenne la
situation est contrastée suivant les
pays
les belges et les néerlandais reviennent
relativement facilement c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué pour les allemands et
les britanniques sont en très forte
chute comme on peut comme on peut s'en
douter il ya un tourisme du sud de
l'europe vers la france et notamment on
a de nouveau la venue des clientes à
l'italienne et clientèle espagnole dans
l'hexagone mais ça restera un tourisme
franco français puis c'est une bonne
chose aussi de rester de rester en
france et de redécouvrir notre pays mais
ce qui est évident regardez le japon qui
sait qu'à fermer ses frontières
moralité il n'y aura pas de spectateurs
pendant les jeux olympiques pour une
raison simple c'est tous les pays qui
ont fermé les frontières mais qui ne
sont pas vaccinés ces pays ils vont
passer
soit ils resteront fermées soit on va
passer de déconfinement re confinement
de contrainte en assouplissement je
pense qu'il faut avoir une vision claire
de la situation dans les années qui
viennent si on veut voyager
il faudra être vaccinés car ça deviendra
une condition sinequanone pour pouvoir
voyager et peut-être même peut-être même
plus rapidement qu'on imagine pour
pouvoir aller au concert au restaurant
parce que cette situation est intenable
à moyen terme on a une solution la
solution c'est la vaccination qui est
fiable qui fonctionne bien et donc on
devra certainement en passer par là
d'ailleurs
moi quand je vais en guyane j'ai pas le
choix je suis obligé d'être vacciné
contre la fièvre jaune
on ne me demande pas de d'avoir d'avoir
le choix on est obligé et puis si on
veut partir vers des destinations soleil
faut aller dans nos outre-mer en tout
cas pour ceux qui sont ouverts en
guadeloupe en martinique où on a de très
belle offre d'ailleurs un petit conseil
à un endroit qui est absolument magique
un ça s'appelle les dacquois lodge ce
sont ce sont des maisons sur lot 1 dans
dans la baie de saint françois
on a sa petite annexe son petit bateau
pour y accéder et là on a l'impression
d'être véritablement seul au monde
en sortant de de sa chambre en plongeant
directement dans ses eaux turquoise et
et didier arino nous sommes nous à paris
sous la pluie depuis de nombreuses
semaines maintenant arrêter tout
peut-être envie en tout cas il est un
internaute qui lui n'a pas envie d'aller
voir le soleil a priori en tout cas il
ne cherche pas une destination soleil et
en plus il veut aller à l'étranger cet
internaute est un fidèle du figaro.fr il
s'appelle chris kraus ont salué il nous
demande je veux visiter saint
pétersbourg et moscou de longue date
est-ce que je peux y aller ou pas si
vaccinés ou tests pcr est ce possible
malheureusement non criss cross en tout
cas pas pour le moment puisque la russie
est classé en rouge
il ya actuellement une liste d'une
vingtaine de pays 21 précisément qui
figure en rouge et dans ce lot de pays
rouges on va retrouver l'inde le brésil
et donc la russie ce qui signifie
qu'aujourd'hui il faut absolument un
motif impérieux pour y aller et
malheureusement le tourisme n'en fait
pas partie si on part à l'étranger en
voiture peut-on se faire contrôler le
pass annie terre et il requit ça c'est
une question de lucie valais sur
lefigaro.fr la en théorie oui et dans la
réalité c'est beaucoup moins évident
dans la réalité vous avez de toute façon
beaucoup plus de chance de vous faire
contrôler lorsque vous prenez l'avion
dans les aéroports et je pense que
beaucoup de français ont déjà éprouvé
moins d'ailleurs au départ en france
qu'à l'arrivée au portugal en espagne de
contrôle sont relativement fiable si
vous êtes en train
il ya une chance que vous fassiez
contrôler notamment dans des pays comme
l'italie
en revanche si vous êtes en voiture s'il
ya personne à la frontière pour vous
contrôler ce qui a plutôt tendance est
la norme
voilà c'est un peu les retours qu'on a
du terrain alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
répondre à julien choqué sur lefigaro.fr
figaro live est ce que je suis contrôlé
à la frontière si je vais en espagne en
voiture pour le moment a priori non même
s'il faudra vérifier le type de contrôle
qui sera mis suivant le changement de
couleur de l'espagne puisque encore une
fois aujourd'hui vous pouvez tout à fait
aller en espagne en train en avion en
voiture et en étant français vous n'avez
hormis un formulaire préalable aucun
détail a montré particulièrement manson
1 qui continue à nous suivre merci
ils nous demandent cette fois-ci quid
des autotests sont-ils accepté en
général non l'europe et c'est d'ailleurs
assez contradictoire elle avait allégé
dernièrement c'est c'est formalité
puisque les tests antigénique sont
devenus éligibles dont pouvaient lorsque
vous allez dans des pays comme la grèce
l'espagne montré des tests antigénique
en général de moins de 48 heures en
revanche les autotests sont relativement
peu reconnue à une exception près en
grèce on va vous le permettre dans
certaines îles alors vous avez été
nombreux aussi à nous répondre sur
twitter des sur sur lequel nous avions
teese est depuis hier pour ce rendez
vous que nous avons avec vous depuis 13h
guillotin demandé est-ce qu'il faudra
quand même faire un test pcr si l'on est
vacciné juste avec la première dose
lorsque vous avez une première dose
votre schéma vaccinal complet pour
reprendre la novlangue administratif
n'est pas terminée donc vous n'êtes pas
vacciné si on est vacciné c'est les deux
doses une dose si vous avez le fameux
vaccin de johnson and johnson
il faut encore qu'il s'écoule 14 jours
derrière ce vent là un consensus
européen pour être considéré comme
vacciner la réponse est donc oui il
devra faire un test pcr à propos de
documents pour entrer dans un autre pays
et là on n'est pas sur un autre pays on
est plutôt sur un territoire c'est
géhanne sur twitter qui demandent quels
documents et processus médicaux faut-il
aller pour pour aller à monaco alors
monaco à ce stade-ci potée de monaco et
de mémoire je ne peux que lui conseiller
d'aller voir la carte que l'on tient à
jour tous les jours sur le figaro.fr
monaco exige un test pcr de moins de 72
heures a priori le contrôle pas
systématiquement la frontière en
revanche vous pouvez vous faire
contrôler dans la journée et dans ce cas
là il faudra le montrer
j'aimerais florent payet qu'on revienne
sur les conditions de voyage et est sûre
ce pass sanitaire obligatoire en europe
et les modalités à connaître comment
fonctionne ce pas sanitaire européen on
a
des visuels pour vous aider à comprendre
un peu plus quelque chose parce que
c'est vrai qu'entre le qr code
le test pcr le vaccin le document qu'on
reçoit sur son téléphone ou par mail etc
etc on doit présenter son passeport en
parallèle qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
comment ça se passe expliqué notre et
bien en théorie il faut pas faire grand
chose puisque encore une fois lorsque
vous passez par la case vaccination ou
tests pcr ou antigénique et bien
automatiquement va vous remettre un
document sur lequel figure un qr code
ce document vous pouvez le garder et le
produire à la frontière il suffira aux
douaniers aux policiers qui vont
contrôlera simplement de scanner le qr
code
c'est vrai aussi parfois avant
l'embarquement pour la compagnie
aérienne
donc vous pouvez voir ce document papier
il suffira ensuite via l'application
antico vide qui c'est plus gai avec ce
fameux dispositif européen est bien de
scanner le qr code vos documents seront
apportées automatiquement il ya un petit
détail technique qui est quand même
plutôt malin c'est que c'est des
documents qui sont disponibles hors
connexion
donc lorsque vous arrivez à l'étranger
vous n'avez pas le wifi à l'aéroport par
exemple et bien aucun problème pour
présenter ce qr code j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur cette carte proposée sur le
site du gouvernement voyage depuis et
vers l'étranger avec ses codes couleurs
le vert le orange et le rouge si la
régie peut nous montrer cette carte du
monde sur lesquelles on voit un ensemble
de pays alors là ils ont un peu zoomer
sur les parties verte si on peut avoir
le le la carte dans son intégralité avec
l'ensemble des couleurs pour qu'on
comprenne bien voilà c'est cette carte
là qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion parce
que effectivement sur l'amérique du nord
en particulier on voit que c'est vers
donc on se dit qu'on peut y aller faire
un tour
or cette carte expliqué nous ferons
variés n'explique pas qu'on peut s'y
rendre
eh ben on est typiquement dans l'élément
de confiance et de clarté qu'évoquer
didier arino si on prend cette carte
elle recense uniquement la situation
sanitaire sur place du point de vue
français
elle ne signifie pas du tout que les
français peuvent voyager automatiquement
vers ces pays vers le bon exemple vous
l'avez cité c'est l'amérique du nord
avec les états unis et le canada qui
pour l'instant sont complètement fermée
aux touristes européens et notamment
français
sans réelle perspective
de retour à la normale donc cette carte
il faut la prendre avec beaucoup de
précaution et c'est cette carte
notamment qui devrait évoluer lundi au
terme du conseil de défense sanitaire
si le gouvernement décide par exemple de
placer l'espagne et le portugal en
orange
didier arino vous êtes toujours avec
nous je voulais avoir des informations
parce qu'il ya des internautes qui
s'interroge sur les départs à l'étranger
on vient de voir la carte du monde
il ya quelques ouvertures qui se sont
fait je pensais au maroc et à
l'indonésie pour des gens qui
souhaiteraient dépassé les frontières
européennes qu'est ce qu'on peut leur
répondre oui peuvent ils peuvent aller
au maroc c'est encore plus facile
lorsqu'on a un schéma vaccinal complet
c'est-à-dire les deux vaccins et le
deuxième de plus de 14 ou mais on peut y
aller aussi avec un test pcr
en revanche je sais ce que j'ai bouclé
en début de démission il faut faire
attention parce qu'il ya quelques
douaniers qui visiblement n'était pas au
courant qu'on pouvait accéder aller au
maroc et qui avait pas besoin de motifs
impérieux
donc il est très important de d'avoir
les documents avec soin et et notamment
de passer par une agence de voyages si
on veut en cas de problème se faire
rembourser ou décaler son déplacement
la situation évolue tellement rapidement
que souvent l'administration a du mal à
suivre et y compris d'ailleurs pas au
delà de l'administration y compris nous
tous parfois on finit par se perdre
parce que le changement de règle est
constant mais aller au maroc c'est tout
à fait possible
évidemment c'est d'ailleurs le pays où
on peut aller le plus facilement dans
les pays du maghreb
y compris lorsque l'on n'est pas vacciné
mais que l'on à un test pcr
après la situation là aussi elle peut
évoluer au cours de l'été nous nous
verrons bien mais je pense que cette
année véritablement c'est plus prudent
de pouvoir rester dans l'hexagone car
véritablement la situation est quand
même incertaine
ou alors si on part à l'étranger passer
véritablement par une agence de voyages
traditionnelles de façon à pas vous
retrouver piégé
rappelons que l'an passé il ya il ya eu
tellement de situations les gens n'ont
pas pu se faire rembourser avec des
avoirs qu'ils représentent
les avaloirs qui ont représenté jusqu'à
un milliard d'euros c'est une somme tout
à fait considérable qui étaient bloqués
dans les compagnies aériennes ou dans
les agences de voyages ou dans les
agences de voyages en ligne pour
lesquels il était vraiment compliqué de
se faire rembourser
donc je crois qu'il faut pas jouer à la
loterie faux si on a très très envie
d'aller à l'étranger c'est quand même de
prendre les précautions d'avoir les
documents sur soi est une nouvelle fois
plus plus on a ces documents sur soi et
plus on a de chance de pouvoir aller à
destination et c'est quand même le butin
les vacances le but des vacances c'est
de prendre du plaisir et ne pas être
dans une situation de stress
par exemple une destination qui est
ouverte par exemple en asie c'est à
phuket
c'est à dire la thaïlande c'est
compliqué d'aller en thaïlande en
revanche on peut aller à phuket
à partir du moment où on est vaccinés en
totalité la saison remaniée qui est
finalement assez paradoxal c'est que le
1er juillet on annoncé en grande pompe
le lancement du pass sanitaire européen
qui était censée justement fluidifier
accélérer ses voyages etc et une semaine
à peine plus tard voilà on vous dit
attention maintenant il va falloir
prendre ses précautions et ces vous
parliez didier arino des voyages qui
font évidemment rêver les vacances d'été
ça fait toujours rêver parce qu'on
imagine toujours ses vacances là en bord
de mer avec la plage et et le fantasme
des cocotiers qui vont avec et pour ça
il faut souvent prendre l'avion l'avion
est associée évidemment au départ pour
les grandes vacances
par rapport au trafic aérien justement
que devient-il où en est-il pour pour
cet été
quelles sont les modalités de voyage on
va dire pour ceux qui qui persisteraient
à aller à l'étranger parce qu'ils ont de
la famille à voir et parce qu'il le doit
pour des raisons impérieuses au
personnel là aussi les mêmes les
compagnies aériennes ne font
qu'appliquer les règles qui sont imposés
par les gouvernements
les compagnies aériennes ne décide pas
elle-même de des règles du jeu donc ce
qui s'applique
c'est pas la compagnie aérienne c'est
pas parce qu'on va prendre transavia ou
easyjet ou air france
elle n'a pas ses propres règles elle
applique les règles imposées donc si
vous allez vous voulez aux états unis
vous ne pouvez pas les états unis
puisque nous n'avons pas la possibilité
d'y aller en revanche si vous voulez
aller en espagne et qui a pas de
contraintes bien évidemment la compagnie
aérienne ne va pas
générer des contraintes qui n'existe pas
donc on voit que les règles ce sont les
règles imposées par par les pays le gros
avantage du système du passeport
sanitaire avec le système du qr code
c'est que ça fluidifie le trafic se
taire au lieu de 2 d'arriver à deux
heures avant et de faire des queues pas
croyable là on a la possibilité d'avoir
un parcours client qui est beaucoup plus
qu est facilité qui est beaucoup plus
fluide et c'est d'ailleurs tout
l'intérêt
alors il ya une avancée on peut pas dire
que l'europe n'a rien fait elle a essayé
de s'harmoniser c'est compliqué il ya
des règles mais au moins on a un outil
qui est un outil qui permet de
fluidifier il n'est pas parfait bien
évidemment mais avec la situation en ce
moment est compliqué donc on peut pas
non plus demander de résoudre tous les
problèmes
ce qu'il faut en revanche c'est que le
discours soit un petit peu plus clair
sur les destinations parce qu'on l'a vu
la confusion par exemple les américains
peuvent venir en france sans aucune
difficulté
en revanche nous ne pouvons pas aller
aux états unis donc c'est pas il n'y a
pas de réciprocité il n'y a pas de
chaque pays appliquent appliquent ces
règles et ses lois
bien évidemment là aussi quand on est
français comparent vers une destination
étrangère
moi je conseillerais notre compagnie
nationale
d'abord parce que ils connaissent les
règles du jeu c'est aussi air france est
une grande compagnie et on a la
possibilité en cas de problème d'avoir
un dialogue constructif c'est quand même
pas si évident dans des compagnies pour
lesquels on parle pas la langue où ça
c'est aussi un facteur qui est un
facteur majeur
et puis si on veut aller dans une
destination soleil je le répète pensons
à l'avenir
faisons preuve de solidarité nous sommes
français allons dès que c'est possible
dans nos outre-mer nous avons des
destinations absolument fabuleuse les
anti français laponie la foulée ghazi et
la polynésie qui est ouvert pour
lesquels on peut aller en polynésie
alors c'est loin c'est cher c'est loin
mais c'est la part de rêve
et puis ensuite on espère que la
situation va s'améliorer dans les autres
dans les autres il est notamment à la
réunion et à mayotte plan mallet vous
souhaitiez deux petits éléments
supplémentaires par rapport à votre
question sur les avions d'abord on a
interrogé la plupart des compagnies
d'abord ils ont fait part d'un taux de
remplissage très élevé donc les gens en
tout cas pour le moment même s'ils sont
informés je parle des départs à
l'étranger évidemment n'ont pas annulé
il ya beaucoup de réservations et le
deuxième élément c'est que les
compagnies ont fait de gros efforts en
tout cas jusqu'à certains mois de
l'année on parle d'octobre novembre et
c'est pour que les billets soient à la
fois annulable ou remboursables ce qui
évidemment va rassurer le touriste le
touriste français est en gros vous
prenez aujourd'hui beaucoup moins de
risques à souscrire à prendre votre
billet d'avion
nous arrivons au terme de ce direct et
cette émission spéciale où nous avons
souhaité vous fournir un maximum
d'informations et de conseils pour vous
rassurer en particulier avant votre
départ en vacances ou si vous êtes déjà
sur votre lieu de vacances ou si vous
avez envie de modifier votre projet de
vacances pour cet été merci didier arino
d'avoir été aussi clair et d'abord
fourni autant de bons plans j'espère que
les internautes ont pris note
en tout cas ils pourront revoir le
replay de ce direct sur youtube et sur
lefigaro.fr
merci à vous florent payet d'avoir été
aussi complet et merci pour votre
expertise
aussi pour ce rendez vous que nous avons
souhaité complet et j'espère qu'il l'a
été je vous dis à très vite sur figaro
live et merci encore pour votre
participation
à bientôt